TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
You can now apply for the
next class of the Launchpad
Accelerator.
The equity-free program
will begin on July 17, 2017,
at the Google
Developers Launchpad
space in San Francisco
and will include two weeks
of all-expense-paid training.
We're now accepting applications
at the link in the description
below from several countries
in Asia, Latin America, Africa,
and Europe.
Android Studio 2.3
is now available.
The focus for this release
has been quality improvements
across the IDE.
For more details,
including screenshots
and a video introduction as
well as the link to download,
head on over to the post.
If you build Python code
that you'd like available
on the command line, this
open source tool is for you.
Python Fire generates
command line interfaces
from any Python code.
Simply call the Fire function
in any Python program
to automatically turn
that program into a CLI.
The GitHub link is on the post.
We've made updates to
Firebase Notifications
to help you reach your
users with greater focus.
This release includes a set of
enhancements to the Firebase
Notifications console
that will allow
you to be much more granular
in selecting the audience that
receives your notification.
More details and a
screenshot are on the post.
Stream view and de-bug view
from Firebase Analytics
are being rolled out
to the general public.
Stream view visualizes
events as they
flow into Firebase
Analytics and gives you
a general sense of
how your users are
interacting with your app.
With de-bug view
you can immediately
see which events are being
reported to Firebase Analytics.
More details and some very cool
screenshots are on the post.
We're working on facilitating
better collaboration
between you and the Google
Cloud platform product teams
by upgrading to Issue Tracker,
a tool we use internally
at Google.
We've migrated
all of the issues.
Check them out or file
your own by first clicking
through to the post.
We're collaborating with
CloudEndure a cloud migration
and disaster recovery
provider to offer
a no cost self-service migration
tool for Google Cloud Platform
customers.
It allows you to migrate virtual
machines and physical servers
from their existing
environment into GCP
with near zero downtime and
little to no disruption.
Click through to watch the
webinar and get started today.
At the recent game
developers conference
we announced important
updates to AdMob
that could help you unlock new
business with rewarded video
formats and free unlimited and
real-time analytics reporting.
More details on how
these features help
you monetize your
games more effectively
are on the post linked
in the description
below with all the other links.
Check them out.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this
week's episode of the Dev Show.
And don't forget to
subscribe and share.
Also, if you'd like to check out
some of our previous episodes,
they're right here.